chez-nous inquiétudes en
charente-maritime je vous rappelle que
les ostréiculteurs de marennes oléron
ont dû suspendre la commercialisation
des huîtres à cause semble-t-il d'une
algue toxique
aujourd'hui on craint une catastrophe
économique le terme n'est pas trop fort
et l'enjeu est très important les
ostréiculteurs du bassin oléron
produisent chaque année plus de 45000
tonnes d'huîtres soit près de la moitié
des huîtres creuses consommée en france
une cellule de crise a été installée à
la préfecture de la rochelle on craint
des licenciements
françois privat francis lambert aucune
activité depuis maintenant quatre jours
les ostréiculteurs de port-des-barques
près de marennes ans aurait dû attendre
les résultats des analyses du
laboratoire de l'ifremer
ils savent que cette situation engendrée
par l'algue toxique qui leur interdit de
récolter les huîtres ou de vendre leurs
stocks sur les marchés peut se prolonger
la grande question est de savoir combien
de temps dans la mesure où en supposant
que l'algue quitte à partir
d'aujourd'hui le bassin chose qui est
impossible
il nous faudrait au moins dix jours de
période pour que lui tu deviennes france
ô noble
donc il va falloir attendre au moins
deux semaines au minimum deux semaines
après si ça s'améliore pas ça peut être
plus a tenté incertitude également sur
l'île d'oléron
mais les ostréiculteurs continue à
travailler le naissain qui assurera la
production des mois à venir
après les producteurs l'inquiétude a
gagné les hôteliers restaurateurs qui
redoutent la désaffection des touristes
à quelques jours des vacances scolaires
alors que depuis quelques années la
fréquentation du littoral en cette
période est en hausse constante
il y avait beaucoup de personnes le
week-end qui venaient manger des
assiettes de fruits de mer chez nous
quand ils n'ont plus aucun intérêt de
venir nous voir alors
on a quand même constaté une baisse dans
la clientèle et je pense que ça va nous
voir une répercussion dans le temps des
milliers d'emplois c'est ce que pèse
activités ostréicoles en charente
maritime les professionnels s'accroche à
un espoir
les grandes marées attendues cette
semaine et qui pourrait avoir raison de
l'algue indésirables